when we look out into the cosmos for
alien life many folks look for signs of
water on moons or planets and that's
because life as we know it is dependent
on water and to understand that we just
have to take a closer look at some of
the properties of water
so what you see here are some
molecules of water this might be review
for you every water molecule has
one
oxygen atom and it is bonded to two
hydrogens so that is a hydrogen and that
is a hydrogen
as well
and the nature of that bond it is a
covalent bond which means that the
oxygen shares electrons with each of the
hydrogen atoms but oxygen is more
electronegative and that's just a fancy
way of saying that even though those
electrons are shared they're going to be
spending more time around the oxygen
than around the hydrogens one way to
think about it is oxygen likes to hog
electrons more than hydrogen does and
since the electrons will spend more time
around the oxygen than around the
hydrogen and because it's a bent
molecule with the hydrogens on one side
of the molecule what happens is the side
where the oxygen is where the electrons
spend more time that gets a partially
negative charge so this is the lower
case greek letter delta that just means
partially negative charge and then the
sides where the hydrogens are those
require a partial positive charge
and so what you see here is that a water
molecule is not charged in aggregate but
either side has a partial charge so it
is a polar molecule and so you can
imagine when you put a bunch of water
molecules together what might happen
well the partially positive side of one
water molecule where the hydrogens are
would be attracted to the partially
negative side of another water molecule
and so they would be attracted and this
is known as a hydrogen
hydrogen
bond
and i could keep drawing that this is
going to be partially positive here this
is going to be partially negative they
will attract
this oxygen end is going to be attracted
to that hydrogen end this oxygen is
going to be attracted to that hydrogen
end as well
and so it's this hydrogen bonding that
gives water a lot of the properties that
make it special that as far as we know
for harboring life or for even allowing
life to be possible life as we
understand it needs a fluid environment
things move around and bump into each
other and it's these hydrogen bonds when
the temperature and conditions are
appropriate that allow water to be in
that liquid form where they're strong
enough so that the water stays together
but they're weak enough so that they
allow the water molecules to flow past
each other and not only does it provide
a good fluid environment it's a very
good solvent water is often known as the
universal
universal solvent
but it's worth putting a disclaimer here
even though people will say it is a
universal solvent that does not mean
that it dissolves everything water does
dissolve more things in its liquid state
than anything else we know about but
there are many molecules that it cannot
dissolve well the things that it does
dissolve well are polar molecules or
things that have a charge for example
when sodium chloride dissolves in water
a sodium
ion is positive so that is positively
charged and so you could imagine it
might be attracted to the side of the
water molecules where the oxygen is but
it dissolves well but things that don't
have charge don't tend to dissolve well
in water but even the property that
there are certain things that it does
not dissolve is also good for life later
on in biology we're going to study
phospholipid bilayers where you have
these molecules where one end is
hydrophilic which means it's attracted
to water molecules and then the other
ends are hydrophobic which means they're
not attracted to water molecules and
many evolutionary biologists believe
that this property of having one side
that's hydrophilic and one side that's
hydrophobic would have allowed these
molecules to start collecting into
membranes eventually forming these
spherical membranes which could be the
containers for early cellular life now
another property of water which makes it
very suitable for life is its high
heat
capacity
sometimes you'll hear people say it has
a high specific heat the specific heat
is the amount of energy needed to raise
one gram of water by one degree celsius
and you might say why does that matter
for life well many life forms can only
operate within a certain range of
temperatures and so if it was really
easy to raise the temperature of water
really high or very low temperatures
very fast well that would make it much
harder for life to operate within water
or even life to be made up of water a
related idea to this is that water also
has a high
heat
of
vaporization we talk more about this in
detail in other videos but this is
talking about how much energy does it
take for water to go from its liquid
form to its gas form and this has proven
valuable in many life forms for a form
of cooling where the vaporization of
water evaporative cooling can take heat
away from an organism so that it doesn't
overheat other properties that are
important about water include cohesion
and adhesion
cohesion is the property of water
molecules that is attracted to other
water molecules and you saw it here with
the hydrogen bonds but when you look at
a macro scale you'll see things like
water droplets form you've all seen
water drop or droplets or dew droplets
these droplets couldn't form if not for
the cohesion of water and even one drop
can be an environment in which thousands
of microorganisms can live
adhesion is the property of water where
it can adhere to other things you might
have seen this in a glass test tube
where it looks like the water is kind of
crawling up the top of the sides and
that's because some of the polarity of
the glass molecules of the test tube but
this property along with the cohesion is
what allows water to transport nutrients
say from the roots of a tree all the way
to the top of a tree these properties
are also an action in our own blood
vessels when you get to the really small
blood vessels the capillaries and that
is called capillaries because you have
capillary action of water which is due
to its cohesion and its adhesion
a last property of water and this is not
an exhaustive list is that it is less
dense as a solid so another way to think
about it is ice which is solid water is
less
less dense
than
liquid
water now you might be thinking why does
that matter for life
well imagine the environments where we
think life first arose if you imagine
some type of a pond and this is the
cross section of it
if ice was more dense than liquid water
and for many substances that is the case
the solid form tends to be more dense
than what would happen if it's cold up
here in the air say in the winter then
this part would freeze but then as it
got more dense it would sink to the
bottom right over there then the next
surface water would freeze and sink to
the bottom and then over time the entire
lake or the entire pond would freeze
over and life would not be able to live
in that pond because when water freezes
it breaks membrane-bound structures as
we know it
and so that would not be suitable for
life but because ice is less dense than
water what typically happens is just
that top layer freezes and then it'll
freeze down as things get colder and
colder but you have an entire
environment where life can continue to
thrive even when the air is much colder
than what is suitable for life and
because of water's high specific heat
that temperature variation in that water
is going to be much less than the
temperature variation outside of the
water either in the air or on the land
so this is just an introduction but
hopefully it makes you appreciate water
a little more and remember and i've said
this in other videos we are mostly water
one way to think about it is that each
of us is made up of trillions of cells
which are primarily made up of water and
exist in a water-based environment they
coordinate with each other and
eventually have emergent complexity that
thinks that it is a sentient being like
each of us